well we now essentially have two major
counter offenses by the counter offenses
by the ukrainians right now the one in
the south it was well over a week into
it now almost two weeks into it
uh a herzone region that is a very slow
and methodical counter defensive where
the ukrainians are trying to encircle
and slowly cut off supply lines to
well-fortified and well-armed
russian troops numbering well over 25
000 but just in the last 48 hours we've
had a second surprise counter-offensive
by the ukrainians this one in the
northeast of
area harakiv is the second largest city
uh in ukraine it's always been held by
the ukrainians but east
and south of harakeev have been widely
controlled by the russians the harakiv
region if you will that is what the
ukrainians want to change and that is
what their most recent counter-offensive
there is trying to accomplish and by all
early indications they the ukrainians
are being quite successful in this
according to uh president vladimir
zielinski and backed up with social
media accounts and video from the area
it appears that the ukrainians have
already captured several recaptured i
should say several villages and are on
the cusp of encircling a very key city
of balaclira this is a city of 25 000
people that was uh within the hands of
the russians for many months now and
it's on a a key strategic point for the
russians uh the ukrainians attacked that
uh under fierce battles in the last 24
hours and it appears that the ukrainians
are very close to potentially retaking
that small yet strategically important
city big picture here is that there's
been some doubt if the ukrainians could
mount a successful counter-offensive
offensive uh
operations in war are much more
difficult than defensive operations and
it appears right now the early stages
that the ukrainians are having some
success
we're even hearing from some uh
pro-russian bloggers and analysts and
they are even indicating that the fight
for the russians in the kharkiv region
is not going as well as the russians
would would like and gabe also close by
belarus says it's begun military
exercises near the polish border what's
the significance of that development
well belarus of course is uh a key ally
of russia uh russia has some military
personnel and operations there uh not
surprisingly and it's a geographic
location of course belarus it plays a
key geo-political role uh here in terms
of where it's located bordering poland
bordering ukraine uh
and so where this uh uh uh
military tr uh operations are happening
or where this military uh uh
exercises are taking place it's on the
south uh west corner of belarus it's
only about 200 kilometers
east of the polish capital of warsaw and
it's only about 300 kilometers north of
the ukrainian city of levive so it might
be a way for the for the
belarus to sort of assert themselves if
you will the belarus defense ministry
saying that this was operation they plan
to go on until september 14th uh
military exercises i should clarify and
they say that they're doing it to
liberate territory temporarily seized by
the enemy in their words and basically
to bolster their uh defenses along the
border regions so of course the polish
authorities and ukrainians will be
watching this very closely given how
these exercises uh military exercises
are so close to their borders i'm sure
they will thank you for the update to
gabe elizondo live for us in kiev